so I've got a new skill video coming up
about the scale of nuclear explosions
and I really want to use ambergen and so
I've tasked Jordan with basically
becoming an emergent expert because
Jordan is very good at Learning
[Music]
[Applause]
so we just finished watching some of my
old work from my high school days and
even though it's objectively terrible I
remember those days very fondly out of
high school I had a very strict game
plan in mind for my future I was gonna
get into USC film school I was going to
do four years graduate summa [ __ ] laude
start working at Warner Brothers and by
the time I was 50 be a senior editor
there I didn't really have any
experience of anyone else's skill set
outside of myself and so when I was
rejected I was shook completely and it
kind of kicked me on my butt because I
didn't really have a backup that's what
kind of shifted me into the Community
College path I got rejected again from
USC another year later and then rejected
for a third time I was very grateful to
have received an acceptance letter from
Chapman I met some absolutely incredible
people people who I still call a friend
to this day people who share the same
passion as you and who are just as
driven as you and it's exciting it's
really exciting that to me made it worth
it but you know I was limited in some
respects of what I was allowed to study
and you know I just paid all the money
that I'd saved my entire life
essentially and I hadn't gotten to take
a class that I wanted that summer I came
to a very difficult decision where I had
to decide do I want to go back I'm at a
point now where I'm only a few thousand
in debt
I have two more years on my docket two
more years that I don't even know that
I'll enjoy I've met some fantastic
people I can stay in touch with them
but maybe it's time to Branch off but I
called up Chapman and I said you know
don't hold my spot I'm not coming back
I'm gonna learn for the task that is
directly ahead of me and over the years
I will hopefully acquire enough of a
skill set to tackle anything that comes
my way and that is a mentality that I
maintain today so today I want to share
my personal do's and don'ts of
self-teaching with you
the first step here is structure picking
a teacher who knows what they're talking
about and taking a structured course is
often the most efficient way to get
started and move forward for me I'm
currently underway continuing my studies
in Houdini and for that I've used CG
circuit where I have access to some
incredible teachers and some fantastic
curriculum for very affordable prices
I've also started moving down the rabbit
hole at Rebel way and they have much
larger albeit more expensive courses but
I feel like I'm at that point in my
studies where I want to invest to that
degree that has provided me a roadmap
for the next two and a half years which
is very exciting because I know and I've
seen from the structure of the course
where I can be in those years
[Music]
scheduling your time some of us have a
lot of time some of us have just a
little bit but don't allow that to be an
excuse to not carve out something for
yourself whether it be early in the
morning which is my preference late at
night on a long drive or even on a lunch
break find time to invest in yourself
and protect that time it's not easy
getting up that early but it's most
definitely worth it another element of
optimizing yourself learning is the idea
of removing distraction I could have a
browser open on my second monitor I have
the drive constantly to look at social
media every time that you break that
Focus you need to ramp back up to being
optimal and so I intentionally remove my
phone from my workstation I
intentionally turn off my secondary
monitors protecting that focus is just
as important as protecting that time
direct focus on one task for 50 minutes
at a time can be challenging it can be a
chore but it gets easier every single
time you do it
unlike the other Jordan I do most of my
learning away from the computers I'm
doing producing I'm doing sword fighting
I'm doing Muay Thai so I need a wallet
that's going to keep up with my active
lifestyle so that's why I'm here to talk
to you about today's sponsor Ridge so my
favorite thing about the ridge wallet is
that it comes in over 30 colors and
styles this wallet is made with RFID
blocking technology that protects you
from digital pickpocketers also each
wallet comes with a lifetime warranty
the wallets have over 50
000 five-star reviews The Ridge team is
so confident that you'll like it that
they'll let you test drive it for 99
days you can send it back for a full
refund if you don't like it I keep our
little security card in here because I
actually just used it today to get into
the studio welcome Jordan there's room
for 12 different cards in here and plus
there's room for cash on top of the
wallet they also make a bunch of other
amazing great gifts they have this
backpack that's my personal favorite I'm
taking this to Italy they have keyk says
they have watches and they have stylish
Rings If you go to reg.com shorter
current you get up to 40 percent off on
all of these super cool items but that's
only until December 22nd perfect for
Christmas that's ridge.com to get up to
40 off now let's get back to our studies
with Jordan Island now that we have our
structure in place we're off to a
fantastic start but that's only going to
get us so far without consistency
the first step here is to set a goal
this goal is your why or your
overarching reason for learning my
personal why is to one day be able to
create literally anything that pops in
my head which is a lofty goal but it is
very exciting to me don't rely on just
motivation motivation runs out that's
why discipline is so important there are
so many days where you're not going to
feel like doing it but those days are
what your why is for discipline is funny
it's like a muscle that needs to be
built right out the gate it's probably
going to be pretty weak and it is pretty
weak in all of us but the more victories
that you have on days where you're
lacking motivation the stronger you get
in handling those days it's very very
important that if you fail on one day
you don't allow that to be an excuse to
fail on the next
another thing that should be consistent
is the source of your information you
can go on YouTube and you can find so
much amazing free resource there but
just be wary of how many teachers how
many voices you're allowing to guide you
because oftentimes having so many voices
can lead to conflicting information that
will actually slow you down that's why I
think paid courses are such a benefit
because you have a constructed coherent
roadmap from One Singular voice and
that's going to speed you up in the Long
Haul and if you're in a position where
you can't afford a paid course that is
totally okay going to YouTube route
going with free videos you're absolutely
going to find benefit you'll just have
to spend a little bit more time
constructing your own roadmap and
finding ideally a single Voice or single
channel that you can trust to give your
time to and when it comes to consistency
be aware that getting started is
literally always the hardest part but I
promise you that if you can get up and
if you can get in front of that computer
and you can put five minutes in more
often than not you'll find a second one
that will carry you through the entire
study session now that we've got our
structure and consistency in place we
are well on our way but all of it will
be for nothing if we don't retain the
information that we consume and that
leads us to our next topic retention
foreign
the first thing that I'll do is I will
watch a tutorial video from start to
finish doing nothing else but paying
full attention to the video and while I
don't retain a ton from this first
viewing I do get a very good
understanding of where we're about to go
and I can prepare myself for that the
second viewing I take copious notes I
try to write them in my own voice
sometimes I'll read them aloud in a way
I'm trying to teach myself because
teaching something is tremendously
beneficial when it comes to retaining
something but once I feel that I've
fully understood the lesson and have
taught it back to myself I move on to
the third step in my retention process
and that's the actual application
that's getting my hands dirty in the
software doing what I just learned in a
way you're learning by watching you're
learning by teaching and you're learning
by doing and those three things together
build a very very strong foundation for
you retaining the knowledge that you're
learning you've got structure you've got
consistency and you've got a plan for
retention in place there is one more
piece of the puzzle and it is the most
important one it is your mental health
[Music]
when you're trying to learn something
all by yourself it's very very easy to
get in your own head to feel inferior or
like you're not good enough or you're
never going to make it that happens to
all of us you're not weaker for having
those thoughts and it's important to
combat them by remembering the following
things
there is so much talent out in the world
and it can be intimidating when my dad
was young he was a musician primarily
and he had access to a limited amount of
musicians in his area he looks at videos
now and he says wow musicians are so
much better now than they were back then
and I have to say no dad they've always
been that good it's just now we have a
window to the very very best all the
time and that can be very daunting but
the light you need to shine on that is
that their abilities are nothing more
than evidence of what can be done with
enough work that's an empowering thought
and an encouraging thought and one that
you should hold tight the only direct
comparison you should ever really make
is your current self to your past self I
know that I am far away from being the
best in the world at visual effects but
I'm the best that I've ever been and I'm
very very proud of that
and don't feel rushed I want to be the
master of everything that I'm studying
right then and there if you can learn to
appreciate and enjoy the journey on your
way to the top it will be so much easier
for you to sustain your growth
there's a natural tendency in me to be a
bit harsh on myself if you feel you're
moving slow be sure to speak to yourself
with love and kindness It's a process
for everybody more importantly it's a
different process for everybody we all
have our own capacities we have our own
weaknesses and our own strengths that we
bring to the table that makes us unique
but that also needs to make our learning
unique so don't fear these moments don't
stress when they come up look forward to
them as opportunities to grow and become
better today than you were yesterday
there's a saying that I love that says
luck is what happens when preparation
meets opportunity and that opportunity
might not come today or tomorrow or a
week from now but I promise you there
will be an opportunity around the corner
at some point in your life and now is
your chance to get ready for it you got
this
guys thanks so much for watching I hope
you found this information helpful and
if someone came to mind while you were
watching I encourage you to share this
video with them as well because you
never know if it might be exactly what
someone needs to hear if you guys would
like more content like this let us know
by liking subscribing commenting or
going to Corridor digital.com where this
video is originally from and with that
said we heard Corridor are wishing you
the very best on your journey